you
my wife is pregnant right now with our
first child and when people see her with
her big baby bump the first question
people ask almost without fail is is it
a boy or is it a girl now there are some
assumptions behind that question that we
take for granted because of our
familiarity with our own human biology
for human babies we take it for granted
that there is a 50/50 chance of either
answer boy or girl but why is it that
way
well the answer depends on the sex
determination system that has evolved
for our species you see for most mammals
the sex of a baby is determined
genetically with the X Y chromosome
system mammals have a pair of sex
chromosomes one passed down from mom and
one from dad a pair of X's gives us a
girl and an X and a Y together gives us
a boy since females only have X's to
pass on in their egg cells and males can
give either an X or a Y in their sperm
cells the sex is determined by the
father and the chance of producing a
male or female is 50/50 this system has
worked well for mammals but throughout
the tree of life we can see other
systems that have worked just as well
for other animals there are other groups
of animals that also have genetic sex
determination but their systems can be
pretty different from ours birds and
some reptiles have their sexes
genetically determined but instead of
the sex being determined by Dad their
sex is determined by mom in those groups
a pair of Z sex chromosomes produces a
male so these males only have Z's to
give however in these animals one Z and
one W chromosome together as a pair
produces a female in this system the
chance of a male or female is still
50/50 it just depends on whether mom
puts a Z or W into her egg certain
groups have taken genetic sex
determination in completely other
directions ants for example have one of
the most interesting systems for
determining sex and because of it if you
are a male ant you do not have a father
in an ant colony there are dramatic
divisions of labor there are soldiers
that defend the colony there are workers
that collect food clean the nest and
care for the young and there's a queen
and a small group of male reproductive
now the queen will mate and then store
sperm from the males and this is where
the system gets real
interesting if the Queen uses the stored
sperm to fertilize an egg then that egg
will grow up to become female however if
she lays an egg without fertilizing it
then that egg will still grow up to be
an ant but it will always be a male so
you see it's impossible for male ants to
have fathers and male ants live their
life like this with only one copy of
every gene much like a walking sex cell
this system is called a haplotype load
system and we see it not only in ants
but also in other highly social insects
like bees and wasps since our own sex is
determined by genes and we do know of
these other animals that have their sex
determined by genes it's easy to assume
that for all animals the sex of their
babies still must be determined by
genetics however for some animals the
question of whether it will be a boy or
a girl has nothing to do with genes at
all and it can depend on something like
the weather these are animals like
alligators and most turtles in these
animals the sex of an embryo in a
developing egg is determined by the
temperature in these species the sex of
the baby is not yet determined when the
egg is laid and it remains undetermined
until sometime in the middle of the
overall development period when a
critical time is reached and during this
time the sex is completely determined by
temperature in the nest in painted
turtles for example warm temperatures
above the critical temperature will
produce females within the eggs and cool
temperatures will produce a male I'm not
really sure who came up with this
mnemonic but you can remember that when
it comes to painted turtles they are all
hot chicks and cool dudes for some
tropical fish the question of will it be
a boy or will it be a girl isn't settled
until even later in life you see
clownfish all start out their lives as
males however as they mature they become
female they also spend their lives in
small groups with a strict dominance
hierarchy where only the most dominant
male and female reproduce and amazingly
if the dominant female on the group dies
the largest and most dominant male will
then quickly become female and take her
place and all the other males will move
up one rank in the hierarchy in another
very different ocean animal the green
spoon worm the sex of the babies is
determined by a completely different
aspect of the environment for this
species it is simply a matter of where a
larvae happens to randomly fall on the
sea floor if a larva lands on the open
sea floor
then it will become a female but if it
lands on top of a female then it will
become a male so for some species the
question of boy or girl is answered by
genetics for others it's answered by the
environment and for others still they
don't even bother with the question at
all
take whiptail lizards for example for
those desert lizards the answer is easy
it's a girl it's always a girl there are
nearly all female species and although
they still lay eggs these eggs hatch out
female clones of themselves so will it
be a girl or will it be a boy throughout
the entire animal kingdom it does really
all depend on the system of sex
determination for humans that system is
a genetic XY system and for me and my
wife we found out it's going to be a
baby boy